the first three january 6 series have
turned out to be quite the show we found
out that those around trump didn't
believe his lie of a stolen election
trump grifted 250 million dollars from
his followers and apparently the reason
trump claimed he won the election was
all thanks to a drunk rudy giuliani
[Music]
according to nielsen at least 20 million
people tuned in to watch the first night
of the january 6 hearings and just for
perspective that's on par with big
television events like a sunday night
football game and unsurprisingly fox
news chose not to air the hearings they
didn't even go to commercial during the
first night i mean can you imagine if
sean hannity had shown the hearing and
then this came up no more crazy people
no more stolen election talk yes
impeachment and 25th amendment are real
many people will quit we already knew
fox news hosts brian kilmeade laura
ingraham and sean hannity were sexting i
mean uh texting
former white house chief of staff mark
meadows to urge trump to act on january
6th so it makes sense why none of them
would want their viewers to actually
watch the hearings it means that they
would learn the truth for once and
speaking of truth trump was told by his
closest friends and advisors that he
lost the election i made it clear i did
not agree with
the idea of saying the election was
stolen and putting out this stuff which
i told the president was [ __ ] even
trump's own daughter ivanka knew that he
lost i respect attorney general barr
so
i accepted what he said was saying i
gotta hand it to liz chaney in the
committee i mean nothing cuts deeper
than hearing your lover i mean a
daughter saying or oath in front of
millions that you're a loser and despite
everyone telling trump that he lost
there was one person he could count on
to tell him otherwise a drunk rudy
giuliani
or
just rudy giuliani i guess apparently
everyone knew rudy was intoxicated on
election night except for rudy justless
and a former campaign advisor and man
trying to cosplay as bain jason miller
was there anyone in that conversation
who in your observation had had too much
to drink mary giuliani tell me more
about that what was your observation
about his
uh potential intoxication during that
that discussion about
what the president should say uh when
he's addressed the nation on election
night
and the mayor was definitely intoxicated
rudy doesn't need anyone's help
embarrassing himself this is the same
guy that was caught tucking his shirt
into his pants and borat too had melting
hair dye on live tv booked the four
seasons landscaping farted on jen ellis
was on the mass singer and literally
married his second cousin
yes he married his second cousin
this is the man who urged trump to
prematurely declare victory on election
night
oh boy despite trump's former campaign
manager bill stephen urging trump not to
declare victory prematurely trump
ignored him instead he listened to rudy
who was feeding trump's paranoia and
pushing him to make unsubstantiated
claims about ballot harvesting voting
machine tampering and much more and it
was those election lines that helped the
trump campaign grip 250 million dollars
from its supporters the campaign spam
supporters with millions of fundraising
emails claiming that the left-wing mob
was undermining the election and urging
them to fight back these emails were
more annoying than those bad luck chain
emails i get from my aunt cheryl
sorry anne cheryl trump promised his
supporters that the money was going to
an election defense fund however
according to a committee investigator
there was no evidence that such a fund
ever existed instead most of the money
went to groups supporting trump not to
fund court battles the january 6
committee calls this the big rip-off but
i believe a more appropriate title for
this criminal activity is the big grift
now
day
3
was off
to a
slow
start all jokes aside i just want to say
thank you to judge luddig leading up to
january 6 trump was pressuring pence
publicly and privately to reverse the
2020 election trump even used his lawyer
john eastman to pressure pence as well
eastman's theory was that pence could
either reject electoral votes outright
or throw it back to the state
legislators to re-examine
here's the thing though there was no
legal constitutional or historical basis
for this and even though eastman knew
the plan was illegal he still went out
in public and said it was legal pence
repeatedly told trump that he lacked the
constitutional authority to do what
trump wanted but trump wasn't having it
he even went as far as to tell pence he
wouldn't be his friend anymore if he
didn't overturn the election to which
the president says no no no
you don't understand mike you can do
this
i don't want to be your friend anymore
if you don't do this trump sounds like a
six-year-old mob boss on the playground
making threats about who can and can't
go to his birthday party so on january 6
when pence told trump over the phone
that he would not reject the votes or
delay certifying the results trump
called pence a wimp and a [ __ ] and it
was trump's anger and disappointment in
pence that trump supporters heard loud
and clear during his january 6 speech if
pence came we're going to drag
[ __ ] through the streets
[Applause]
[Music]
the danger to pence was real as the mob
got about 40 feet away from the vice
president and a confidential informant
from the proud boys told the fbi that if
the group would have found pence
they probably would have killed him man
to be a fly in mike pence's head when
all of this was going down
but even after the ride at the capitol
eastman would not take no for an answer
on overturning the election he called
former white house lawyer eric hirschman
to talk about it i said to him
are you out of your f in mind
right
i said i
said i only want to hear two words
coming out of your mouth for now on
orderly transition
now the screamer said i don't want to
hear any other fn words coming out of
your mouth no matter what other than
orderly transition repeat those words to
me
eventually you said orderly transition
i said good john now i'm going to give
you the best free legal advice you're
ever getting in your life
get a great fn criminal defense lawyer
you're going to need it hold on what was
that get a great fn criminal defense
lawyer you're gonna need it shortly
after eastman sent rudy giuliani an
email saying i've decided that i should
be on the pardon list if that is still
in the works all right i hope that we
can all agree that anyone asking for a
pardon has clearly done something wrong
so far the first three hearings have
confirmed that trump knew his claims of
a rigged election were not true but he
still made them anyway and he hasn't
stopped since trump is currently rage
posting about the january 6th hearings
on truth social guys he's demanding
equal time so trump if you're watching
this come on down and claim your equal
time liz cheney and the committee would
love to have you well i'm gabe sanchez
and this has been what was that
[Music]